well howdy there welcome to yet another
paw gang tutorial in this video what
we're gonna be talking about is uh we're
gonna talk about how we can modify the
like icon to our game so the way that
we're gonna do that is the following so
we have um at the very top basically is
where we define like all of our you know
images basically and what we want to do
is add an icon well common sense would
say why don't we just make the race car
or icon okay so what we'll do is we'll
just say a PI game dot display dot set
underscore icon and let's just make it
the car image easy breezy beautiful
covergirl so so we do that and we get
this um which I mean it's our car but a
couple of things we notice right out of
the gate it doesn't appear to be
transparent anymore for whatever reason
um the other thing I need to do is get
rid of this mouse movement stuff I think
we'll do that now as well we are
printing out where have you are we okay
printing out click let's stop that
immediately that's enough um anyway
we've got the icon now it has changed
but it doesn't really look that great
I'm a little concerned about the no
transparent background that shouldn't
have been the case but another issue
that might arise is it'll be heavily
distorted and the reason why that will
be here is is because the proper size
for the window icon is 32 by 32 so we
want our icon to be well you guessed it
32 by 32 so what I'll do is I'm just
going to go to my racecar image edit it
now it definitely won't have a
transparent background cuz I'm in paint
but we'll resize it and we can see that
the vertical is 82 horizontal 73 but
probably the best thing to do is make
these identical in size
so now we need to lose two pixels here
ah ah one pixel away oh my goodness all
right let's do it
we got this we got this oh yeah okay
okay yes all right now let's just
control a center this thing a little bit
good enough good enough now resize and
we'll do 32 pixels so we've resized it
and now we'll go ahead and save that as
a car icon
so it's car icon dot PNG yeah that's
fine we'll lose transparency now we can
go a car icon dot PNG let's save and run
that one and wow it looks like utter
junk still and it even appears to be
maybe distorted
sadly even though we're the perfect size
um anyway at least sort of looks like a
race car
I don't honesty the PI game logo looked
like crap too so this is a little bit
better and not as bad as the snake you
can put transparent backgrounds however
I'm not quite sure why that one gave me
such a hard time I'm curious so I'm
going to open up [ __ ] and change the
background on this one and see there is
no reason why you can't have a
transparent background I've done it
plenty of times
so wait file open let's do desktop and
Wow
I think I'm just blind I can't find
anything
index lessons there we go PI game for
Python 3 and car icon
finally nap colors color 2 alpha okay
file export as the same name yes
export and that should be it so now we
should have a transparent car icon so
let's save and run that one more time
and yes still looks like crap but at
least now it's transparent doesn't have
a white white box around it anyway
that's how we can add icons to the
window as well oh no it looks like maybe
we have what have we done oh uh what car
ok I see I see what we've done what was
the name of the original race card at
PNG race card at PNG and then what we
want to do is let's copy this paste and
then we'll call this a game icon and
then copy that paste that in there mmm
now we have the game icon and the proper
size oh my good news it gave us this
life up high game number one troll ok ok
that's fine sure PI game I don't mind
this nonsense so why would that hit oh
we made the same mistake as before game
icon needs to be what do we I forget we
even call this was it car icon I think
this car icon dot PNG Peggy I'm sorry
for calling you troll anyway there we go
final so we're all set now oh man so uh
yes we got that game and we're still
spitting out these Y crossovers probably
before you distribute this game you
should also change that as well so
anyway um so that's it for this one I
think we're almost done with message
display I don't think we're even using
message display anymore probably comment
that out
see if we get away with that that was a
quite a messy function anyway so good
thing good riddance I say
again pause continue awesome so yeah
okay I got rid of that nasty function
nobody liked it anyways alright anyway
that's it for this little batch of Pi
game tutorials as always if there's
something very specific or generally
specific that you want to see with Pi
game feel free to let me know I'm always
open to the idea of making more PI game
videos you just have to have something
you're looking for still can't make
battlefield 3 yet maybe it's coming but
we'll see otherwise if you have any
questions or comments or anything like
that feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and it's a nice time